c'est l'une des conséquences
malheureuses du confinement les
violences à l'intérieur du foyer ont
augmenté depuis quelques semaines
mathilde de biberons soir au sein de la
rédaction tv 60,18 vous parlez vous plus
particulièrement de la hausse des
violences conjugales avec votre invité
oui nous sommes avec gaël démarre
bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes coordinatrice
du collectif nous tout 78
donc je rappelle c'est un collectif qui
milite contre les violences sexistes et
sexuelles depuis le début du confinement
le ministre de l'intérieur a constaté
une hausse des violences conjugales de
30% en france
est ce le même constat dans les yvelines
voyez à priori dans les yvelines ça suit
la même tendance
j'ai pas de chiffres exacts mais on sait
qu'au niveau des plateformes de chat ou
d'appels
il ya une hausse de 20 à 30% des
contacts certaines femmes et enfants
sont du coup confiné avec des personnes
violentes
comment peut-on donner l'alerté à agir
durant leur confinement
alors il ya plusieurs systèmes qui sont
possibles ce que c'est pas toujours
facile d'appeler justement pour donner
des alertes quand l'agresseur est
présent avec nous donc il ya des
systèmes de chat qui sont également
accessibles la nuit sur arrêtons les
violences point gouv.fr il est possible
aussi de contacter par sms le 114
il est possible aussi dans les
pharmacies de donner l'alerté
pharmaciens sont au courant de la
procédure et peuvent contacter ensuite
la police et puis dans les yvelines il
ya aussi des permanences qui commencent
à être mises en place dans les centres
commerciaux donc notamment il y en a une
à plaisir le mardi après-midi de 13h à
17h à auchan et à mantes la jolie le
jeudi de 13h à 17h il ya aussi également
une ligne d'écouté à destination des
auteurs de violences elle a été activée
le 6 avril est-ce que vous pensez que ça
va permettre d'éviter les passages à
l'acte
ça peut éviter le problème c'est que les
auteurs de violences sont pas forcément
conscients en fait du problème qui
peuvent avoir mais si en effet pour ceux
qui arrivent à prendre conscience de ça
je pense que ça peut les aider de
pouvoir d'avoir cette possibilité là
d'en parler à quelqu'un et est ce qu'il
y à d'autres dispositifs mis en place
par le gouvernement
le 39 19 ans dans quel numéro qui est
communiqué par tous donc est joignable
en appelant donc ça c'est vraiment à
numéro qui va permettre d'orienter
ensuite vers d'autres associations qui
pourront aider
plus précisément et puis pour les
enfants il ya le 119 aussi si jamais
vous entendez des enfants qui crient
qu'ils peuvent êtres en souffrance
n'hésitez pas à contacter le 119 pour
alerter et en cas d'urgence absolue si
vous sentez qu'il ya une mise en danger
c'est de 17 qu'il faut appeler la police
merci d elle démarre d'avoir répondu à
nos questions merci à vous et merci à
vous mathilde je précise d'ailleurs dans
les yvelines plusieurs acteurs sont
engagés dans la lutte contre les
violences faites aux femmes on parlait
de cette association ce collectif nous
tout il ya également le cidff qui est le
centre d'information pour le droit des
femmes et des familles qui a cinquante
antennes sur le territoire alors en ce
moment forcément un tout est remise en
question mais en tout cas le numéro qui
s'affiche vous pouvez le joindre à
montigny le bretonneux
il ya également un centre qui s'appelle
équinoxe 1 qui héberge l'étincelle c'est
un lieu d'accueil de jour des victimes
enfin il ya aussi une autre association
l'association women safe qui prend en
charge ces femmes victimes de violence
ainsi que leurs enfants